Let's try that same example
function now in Python code.
So up here we have our normal imports,
here is where we define the function
and again we're simply
using X-1.5 squared +0.5.
Now within this function
we're going to go ahead and
print what the value
is when we get called.
It just is a little bit handier so that
we can see what exactly is going on.
But you don't have to
have that of course.
And then we return y.
Now this is going to be the function
that we're going to Ask SciPy,
or in particular the optimizer,
to minimize for us.
And by the way, we've included
this optimize package as spo.
So scipy.optimize as spo.
This is our call now to the optimizer or
the minimizer.
Before we call it we first set
our guess value to be 2.0.
And we're using the function minimize so
we call spo.minimize.
F, that's our function here,
so we're saying minimizer,
please minimize find the minimum for
this function.
X guess is our guess.
Method is, we're directing minimize to
use a particular minimizing algorithm.
We'll talk a little bit about
that a little bit later.
But this is one of those particular
algorithms that happens to
work pretty nicely.
We send it one more option here,
disp, which is True.
Which means we just want it to be
verbose about things that it discovers.
Anyways, that's it.
That calls the minimizer.
The minimizer repeatedly
calls our function and
finds the minimum value,
then it prints out those results.
Let's try a test run and
see what happens.
Remember, in our function
that we wanted to minimize,
we explicitly printed X and Y.
So here you can see each time it gets
called it prints these values out.
And so the minimizer is repeatedly
calling that function f and
it's printing these things out.
So it gets called initially
with an X of 2 and
it discovers that the value is 0.75.
Then a value slightly greater than 2,
a value slightly less than 2.
And the minimizer very quickly converges
on 1.5 as the answer, and here
it prints out those values and finds the
minima at 1.5 with a value of 0.5 there.
So pretty efficient and
effective discovery of the minimization.
I added a few more lines of
code here which I'll highlight,
merely to plot the answer, so
all the rest of the code is the same.
But let's take a look now
if we plot it as well.
So, same result as before but nice plot
with our minima identified right here.
So, that is how to code up a minimizer,
it's really very easy and very powerful.
Let's look at it a little bit further.